euh on va recevoir pour l'instant pierre
boton un ami qui j'aime beaucoup un ex
détenu qui se bat depuis des années pour
améliorer les conditions de détention
des prisonnier il a fait deux passages
en prison et à la suite de son deuxème
passage il n'a qu'un seul constat le
système carcéral va très très mal il va
nous en dire plus ce soir Nant PMP petit
récap il est avec nous juste après c'est
parti condamné deux fois pour abus de
bien sociaux pierre boton a passé de
nombreux jours derrière les barreaux de
la prison de freine et de celle de la
santé 602 jours il y a 25 ans et l'âge
17 mois et 7 mois de semiliberté 24 mois
incarcéré une première fois à la fin des
années 90 puis une autre fois en 2020 il
affirme qu'en seulement 20 ans tout a
changé et tient aujourd'hui à se faire
entendre l'ex détenu explique que les
prisons françaises sont aujourd'hui
gangrainés par la violence où les
surveillants sont dépassé et les détenus
y font régner la
loi violence sexe secret quartier VIP
pierre boton raconte les coulisses des
prisons françaises ce soir dans
[Musique]
TPMP merci Pierre boton d'être avec nous
ex détenu auteur du livre qb4 ce qui se
passe en prison est pire que ce que vous
croyez merci Pierre je suis très heureux
de te voir d'ailleurs comment çaan- tu
toi h ah oui je l'adore pierre vous êtes
content de le voir non tout le monde est
content de voir Pierre bouton à chaque
fois c'est vrai même dans les couloirs
tout le monde était content de te voiras
une sérénité là tu es tu es bien tout va
bien mon pierre ça va tu es heureux ça
va bon alors toi tu as fait deux deux
séjours en prison je veux dire séjours
même si je devrais pas dire ça déjà
est-ce que tu peux réexpliquer au
téléspectateurs pourquoi tuelle en
prison pour abus de bien social ouais
voilà exactement à 25 ans d'écart oui ce
qui veut dire quelque chose c'est que la
prison ne sert à rien ah ouais c'est ça
et que je suis l'exemple vivant de
l'échec du système pénitentiaire c'est
ça qu'il faut à 25 ans d'écart tu as
fait la
même exactement les mêmes faits ouais
c'est fou donc en fait toi tu dis tuas
fa ça ça t'a pas guéri de faire de la
prison c'està direire quand on est en
prison on passe 22h sur 24 en cellule
ouais moi on m'a pas mis au contact de
gens des des impôts on m'a pas mis au
contact de gens de la de comptable on
m'a pas appris à comment tenir une
comptabilité on m'a même pas on m'a même
pas utilisé pour la société c'est-à-dire
on m'a même pas mis dans un épad pour
aider les gens à nettoyer les les les
personnes âgées on ne m'a même pas mis
dans un hôpital pour essayer d'aider les
gens c'està dire je pense sincèrement
pour certaines peine pour certaines
peines la prison c'est un échec c'est un
c'est un système qui échoue depuis 40
ans dans lequel on ne change rien et
j'ai voulu témoigner parce que j'étaéis
très impressionné par ce que j'ai vu la
deuxième fois alors justement g est-ce
qu'on peut rappel no téléspectateur qui
est Pierre boton parce qu'il était en
quartier VIP oui pierre boton c'est un
homme d'affaires français qui a été
condamné une prem première fois qui
était lié à l'homme politique Michel
Noir voilà donc condamné pour abus de
biens sociaux à 2 ans c'est ça et puis
vous avez été condamné vous êtes sorti
vous avez été condamné une deuxième fois
et là vous étiez effectivement en
quartier VIP et vous avez pris
conscience comme vous l'exprimez très
bien là que la prison n'est pas la
réinsertion du tout au contraire vous en
êtes l'exemple ça peut inciter à la
récidive et là vous vous êtes dit il
faut que je témoigne pour aider ceux qui
sont détenus parce que les conditions
sont insupportables ce que vous avez vu
vous a pter et révolteré alors surtout
c'est le décalage avec les 25 ans
d'écart oua c'est-à-dire si vous voulez
il y a 25 ans j'étais également dans ce
qu'on appelle le quartier VIP mais qui
n'existait pas il y a 25 ans c'était
vraiment un quartier VIP cette fois-ci
absolument pas je vais expliquer ce que
c'est le quartier ce qu'on appelle le
quartier VIP c'est un étage avec 18
cellules d'accord qui est occupé par 18
détenus il y a deux cellules doubles il
y a également une cellule antiscide et
ce ce quartier est juste placé en
dessous du du quartier arrivant tout
détenu qui arrive en prison reste une
semaine dans un quartier qu'on appelle
le quartier arrivant et je peux vous
assurer que c'est pas du tout un
quartier VIP je sais que vous avez reçu
ici des gens qui vous ont dit l'inverse
c'est faux j' étais il y a un Anin donc
donc c'est totalement faux en revanche
le ce que je trouve terrible c'est
loisiveté vous savez il y a 10 ans j'ai
mené un combat avec des résultats
d'ailleurs pour lutter pour
l'amélioration des conditions de
détention j'ai fait une erreur c'était
pas le bon le bon le bon combat ce
n'était pas le bon combat le combat
c'est à quoi sert la prison ouais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pendant le temps de
prison comment on occupe moi j'ai 68 ans
donc bon mais les gamins ils ont 20 22
23 on les on les on les enferme dans des
cellules pendant 22 he ils n'ont rien à
faire imaginez-vous ça ils n'ont rien à
faire vous savez si je peux me permettre
de dire j'ai j'ai vu je porte pas Eric
du poriti dans mon cœur comme tous les
traîtres d'ailleurs euh 1 an avant
d'être incarcéré un an avant d'être
incarcéré il a signé avec l'Observatoire
inational des prisons qui est une
association remarquable une circulaire
contre la surpopulation
carcérale aujourd'hui sous son ministère
il n'y a jamais eu autant de détenus
alors je sais ce que vont dire les
français c'est bien fait on s'en fout
c'est des délinquants et ainsi de suite
ok très bien et je suis d'accord
mais la sécurité des Français se joue en
partie en prison parce que je vais vous
expliquer quelque chose à vous tous si
je vous mets dans une cellule prévue
pour deux à qu avec deux détenus plus
forts que vous qui vont vous dire porte
la Dieu là-bas ne regarde pas cette
émission parce que c'est pas une une
émission qui va avec nos valeurs qui
vous dit fais la prière je vous mets au
défi tous que vous êtes là au bout d'un
mois et demi de ne pas céder un petit
peu et tous vous avez des épaules vous
êtes exposés prenez ça sur des gamins de
23 ans qui ont été élevés dans un milieu
très défavorisé qui depuis le début sont
desolarisé qui depuis le début sont au
contact de la
drogue c'est ça la prison et si les
Français veulent que ça continue je leur
dis
aujourd'hui les règlements de compte à
Marseille on Arve plus à les arrêter h
il y a une balle perdue d'une étudiante
dans sa chambre bien sûr en fait dans sa
chambre ouis oui combien de temps on va
accepter ça combien de temps on va
continuer à accepter ça j'étais avec des
gamins qui avaient 18 ans il n'avait il
il savait pratiquement pas écrire mais
il savaiit ce queétait une Kalashnikov
ils savaient ce que c'est un
glock c'est ça mais vous êtes bien
conscient que les Français n'acceptent
pas ce discours les Français ils veulent
que lorsqu'il y a une sanction la
personne l'exécute en prison je veux
dire on a malheureusement une société
qui est extrêmement
violente il y a a ce dont vous parlez
des des faits
divers la situation à Marseille il y a
aussi de la délinquence en col blanc
vous en avez malheureusement été victime
mais les Français ils acceptent pas que
les les que qu'à un moment donné il y
ait une justice réparatrice à quoi vous
faites allusion mais on va expliquer aux
gens que quelqu'un qui est condamné va
finalement rester
dehors pas tout ce que je dis c'est pas
du tout ce que
dis c'est par
pass je dis pas qu' de sanction je ne
dis pas qu'il faut pas de peine je ne
dis pas qu'il faut même pas pas mettre
les gens en prison je dis même l'inverse
je vous dis seulement que pendant que
vous les avez ces gamins je sais que
j'ai choquer chez les Français à les
appeler des gamins mais moi j'ai été
incarcéré avec le
complice de l'assassin de C melpatti
pendant 3 semaines il y a très peu de
gens qui ont pu discuter avec lui il a
18 ans le gosse à 13 ans on lui offre un
couteau en céramique c'est qui on qui
lui offre ou son son père je crois pour
son anniversaire qui vient de Turquie
vous imaginez comment vous voulez le
sortir merci de faire
le comment comment vous voulez le sortir
donc vous parlez de la surpopulation
carcérale c'est surt ça je vous dis je
vous dis qu'il faut changer les prisons
Pier qu'est-ce c'est hyper intéressant
ce que vous dites s'il vous plaît on
s'arrête de petites minutes là-dessus
qu'est-ce qui vous a dit le le complice
de l'assassin de Samuel Pat c'est
intéressant ça c'est intéressant c'est
hallucinant je suis d'origine lyonnaise
et il est de la région lyonnaise oui et
c'est juste hallucinant vous savez en
prison j'ai vu
des des gens qui ont pris 28 ans qui ont
tué j'étais avec ces gens-là qui ont tué
et violé une femme handicapée qui ont
pris 28 ans de tôle c'était des boules
de ner ils cherchaient la bagarre avec
n'importe qui compris avec moi c'était
d'un ridicule son nom lui hyper calme
très calme il vous dit euh son parcours
donc c'est quoi son parcours al bah son
parcours déscolarisé à l'âge de 14 ans
il dit comme euh comme le le le monsieur
le le pardon excusez-moi le terroriste
qui a tué le le dernier professeur que
c'est à cause de son père oui c'est ça
pardon excusez-moi c'est son père et il
dit que il était pas vraiment tenté par
les armes mais il a été tenté par la
religion ce gamin il est blanc
hein non mais non mais c'est important
hein d'entendre ça le gamin il est blanc
il est bouffé
d'acné il a 18 balets Comment comment il
comment il il il il justifie
euh l'attentat de de Samuel patine mais
Cyril je lui dis mais qu'est-ce que tu
as fait il m'a dit ben moi c'était mon
copain et il nous a envoyé un message en
disant aujourd'hui pensez à moi parce
que j'ai un examen il dit moi je voilà
ce qu'il me raconte hein je pensais que
Ctait un examen de ma et moi en fait il
m'aenvoyé la photo de la tête décapitée
de Samuel pati je m'excuse pour la
famille de Samuel patide rappelez ça ça
doit être horrible pour eux et vraiment
je m'en excuse mais il faut que les
Françis le sache bien sûr le gamin je
lui dis mais comment tu as pu regarder
ça moi j'en ai jamais vu et même si
j'avais l'occasion d' voir je va pas
avir je dis mais comment tu as pu
regarder ça et il me dit mais moi Pierro
ça fait depuis 14 ans j'en regarde j'en
regarde tout le temps ouis voilà le
monde dans lequel ils évoluent il faut
absolument que que vososos vos
téléspectateurs prennent conscience de
ça mais donc et lui il a pris il a pris
combien ah il a pas pris il est pas jugé
mais il s'attend à faire 30 ans donc lui
reproche quoi c'est quoi il c'est quoi
je crois je crois qu'il a il a envoyé
d'abord quand on l'a arrêté il a agressé
les les gendarmes avec un couteau mais
ensuite il a envoyé la photo de la tête
décapité dans un groupe je suis pas un
pro de ça mais dans un dans un dans un
groupe et et même sil prend tant temps
même il prend 40 ans il a 18 ans ça fait
58 il a encore 10 ans de moins que moi
bien sûr il va sortir il va
sortir et là ce gamin là au lieu est-ce
qu'il regrette est-ce qu'il regrette t
pr est-ce qu'il vous a dit qu'il pose
même pas la question il se pose même pas
la question il dit quoi il se dit je
suis ici il est ailleurs pour lui c'est
un drame d'être en prison ou pas du tout
c'est il faut le payer mais ça va il
faut payer voilà vous nous avez parlé de
juste avant vous avez donné l'exemple de
de deux personnes avec qui vous étiez
incarcéré aussi quoi qui qui avait euh
violer une personne handicapée euh ces
personnes-là elles sont
elles disent quoi elles regrettent elles
sont dans l'ré ell disent pas du tout
non elles disent quoi dis NON NON alors
là je je suisisêtre très très sévère
hein euh et je vaistre très sévère et je
vais choquer beaucoup de gens peut-être
Gill pour moi en prison il y a des gens
qui sont irrécupérables non ben sont je
je vraiment je le dis j'ai j'ai
rencontré des gens voilà euh je je sais
que c'est pas bien hein pour par rapport
à par rapport à l'humanité Mo j'ai moi
j'ai j'ai des potes qui ont fait de la
prison pendant très longtemps même 18
ans des grosses peines 20 ans 22 ans et
qui aujourd'hui sont vraiment dans
lainertion qui sont sortis depuis des
années qui sontt vraiment qui sont voilà
qui sont passés à autre chose mais
Pierre quand tu dis ces deuxl ces deuxlà
pour toi ils étaient irrécupérables ils
sont irrécupérables ah bah parce que
c'est des c'est des détenus que le
système pénitentiaire se balade de
prison en prison partout où ils sont dès
qu'ils sont en cellule on l'ouvre la
cellule ils agressent les surveillant
ils agressent en cours de promenade euh
voilà enfin voilà intéressant non mais
non mais ok s'il vous plaît merci euh
donc ouais donc il ils vous ont agressé
vous il a essayé ouai il a essayé de me
raquetter voilà bon malureusement je
suis un vieux bonhomme et ouais j'ai un
petit peu de caractère même en prison et
j'ai j'ai pas voulu et j'étais au
service médical et il y a le médecin qui
me dit Monsieur boton faites attention
parce que cette personne-l on l'a trouvé
avec des larmes de rasoir dans sa
chaussette donc faites attention faites
attention à vous
et alors il s'est passé quoi rien il est
plus revenu ils sont plus non non rien
mais c'est mon cas personnele
ance quand vous avez dit tout juste tout
à l'heure vous avez dit une phase vous
avez dit le quartier entre guillemets
VIP n'a rien de VIP pourquoi non il a
rien c'est je même vous dire la les les
détenus qui font des allersretours
beaucoup parce que il faut savoir que 60
% des détenus récidives donc c'est quand
même un système qui échoue lequel on ne
change surtout pas la méthode et surtout
pas les hommes voilà surtout ça on ne
change pas voilà donc les gens
continuent à faire leur carrière et
ainsi de suite enfin bon peu importe
et ce quartier là par exemple voyez moi
j'avais un un tapis gym ouais on l'a pas
laissé c'est pas autorisé
ouais alors que vous avez dans toute la
prison de la drogue des téléphones des
chichas mais c'est ça c'est que le
quartier VIP à limite est plus surveillé
que les autes c'est ça en fait bien sûr
donc en fait comme vous êtes sé vous
avez le droit de faire moins de choses
bah surveill les surveillants passent
plus dans les quartiers VIP que dans le
quartier normal vous savez la la preuve
c'est ton invitation Cyril je suis
peut-être plus dangereux pour le
sérafice pour le système
pénitentiaire que d'autres donc il était
important que le système trouve
peut-être quelque chose à me reprocher
ce qui n'a pas été le cas est-ce qu'on
est mélangé aux autres détenus quand on
est dans le quartier VIP ou est-ce qu'on
est que entre VIP non non alors tout
dépense vraiment ce qu'on appelle les
VIP si si si quelqu'un qui a pris 28 ans
et qui a
violé une femme handicapée et l' tué
c'est un VIP alors oui on est mélang je
suis j'ai été mélangé avec ces gens-l
j'ai été mélangé avec un cannibal
j'aiété mélangé avec un gars
complètement enfin
voilà pas avec tous les autres détenus
de la prison c'est là qu'on dit VIP que
font ces gensl dans le quartier VIP ah
oui c'est ça ils sont isolés ils sont
isolés du reste ils sont isolés du en
fait on vous on n'a pas pour ça je dis
le terme le terme VIP n'existe plus il
existait c'est vrai quand moi j'étais
avec Bernard tapi avec voilà avec Gelfi
enfin avec Bob Denard il y a il y a 25
ans là le le ça n'existe plus en fait
c'est le quartier des vulnérable
c'est-à-dire c'est des gens qu'on
protège du reste de la détention ou
qu'on isole du reste de la détention
soit parce qu'on arrive pas à les gérer
soit parce que peut-être ils auraient
tendance à eux gérer la détension juste
pierre pierre tu étais tu étais tu étais
un carcér un cannibal aussi tu ouais
[__] tu étais tout seul avec lui dans
la cellule dans la cellule ah non non
non moi j'étais seul dans la cellule lui
il était tout seul oui mais bien sûr oui
mais avec avec avec un gars qui a violé
deux femmes et qui les a massacré à coup
de casque pour pas qu'elle puisse
leonnaîre justement pierre parce que
c'est intéressant ton témoignage parce
que c'est d'accord toi ton cas ton cas
c'est vrai que tu dis voilà moi mon cas
c'est j'ai pas envie qu'on en parle mais
justement tu as pu parler avec ces avec
ces ces détenus qu'est-ce qu'il te
disait par exemple le cannibal qu'est-ce
comment est-ce que tu as pu parler avec
lui il y a une phrase il y a une phrase
où je suis pas représentatif pour une
fois des détenus c'est que la la prison
est remplie d'innocents ce qui est pas
mon cas ouais voilà donc moi je
reconnais voilà j'ai ou je conteste
totalement ma peine le montant de ma
peine c'est juste hallucinant mais en
revanche voilà je j'ai pas été condamné
pour rien mais oui et donc il en a
beaucoup qui disent non moi j'ai oui la
plupart la plupart et puis il faut il
faut savoir une autre chose là encore je
je risque de choquer le les humiliations
faites à la famille
lors des parloires la surpopulation ça
veut dire beaucoup de choses ça veut
dire quoi les humilations fait à la
famille jeis t'expliquer en fait ça veut
dire que vous pouvez pas avoir beaucoup
de parloir ça veut dire que vous pouvez
plus d'avoir d'activité parce qu'il y a
trop de détenus par rapport au aux
activités prévues qui sont déjà pas
terrible vous il y a pas assez de
surveillant pour vous ouvrir la porte et
ainsi de suite ben je je vais te donner
une
humiliation lorsque les visiteurs
viennent en au parloir ils passent sous
un portique et ce sonne si jamais il y a
des choses métalliques
et ma fille est venue une fois elle a
fait 45 minutes elle a sonné on pensait
que c'était un bracelet qu'elle avait
qu'il fallait une un tournevis pour
l'enlever mais c'est pas ça personne ne
lui dit rien donc elle est venue pour
rien elle a pas pu rentrer et la
deuxième fois ça recommence à sonner en
fait c'est l'armature de son
soutiengorge vous pensez pas que les
surveillants ils le savent ça et j'ai
beaucoup de considération pour les
surveillants mais vous pensez pas qu'ils
le savent et vous pensez pas que qu' ils
peuvent le dire qu'il qu'on peut faire
une petite affichette et là j'en veux
beaucoup à duupont Moretti mais beaucoup
il se disaient défenseur des des détenus
c'est compliqué quand on estgarde des
sauts de faire une affichette pour
éviter ses ses humiliations il préfère
aller faire un flyer mais est-ce qu'
est-ce qu'il s'est déplacé dans les
prisons Éric du P une fois une fois oui
bah maintenant il se déplasse pour
inaugurer celle des autres qui sont
évidemment construites sur le même sur
le
même sur sur le même mode que que que
les autres et il s je pense pas que si
savez sa première visite a été à freine
où il s'est fait applaudir par les
détenu je suis pas persuadé que cette
scène là qui d'ailleurs n'était pas
forcément souhaitable puisse avoir lieu
une deuxième fois il y a est-ce qu'on
fait rentrer ce qu'on veut en prison ou
pas ouais vraiment ouais comment bah moi
je suis pas j'ai vu beaucoup de choses
rentré notamment la drogue c'est juste
hallucinant on est dans un endroit où on
doit faire respecter vous savez ce qu'on
par beaucoup la la prison à
l'administration pénitentiaire à
l'éducation nationale c'est c'est la
règle de pas de vague faut pas de vague
ça surtout pas de mutinerie surtout pas
d'agression sur où on a complètement
lâché les gens de terrain la hiérarchie
a totalement lâché les gens de terrain
les pauvres surveillants ils se trouvent
au contact de la violence des crachats
de et me dites pas ne me dites pas
qu'une administration digne de ce nom
ne peut pas mettre des chiens pour vous
trouver la drogue et les téléphones il y
en a de partout alors on dit il y a des
brouilleurs mais les gars ils ont des
routeurs donc voilà c'est réglé me dites
pas ou alors ce ce ce ce pays est est
est plus bas que tout ne me dites pas
que dans un endroit clos où on met des
gens dont on sait qu'ils sont
délinquants dont on sait qu'ils sont
liés à la drogue qu'on ne peut pas
contrôler l'utilisation de la drogue et
l'entrée de la drogue on laisse faire on
laisse faire on laisse faire
calien s vous plaît attendez ça calme
peut-être mais en même temps que la
drogue vous faites rentrer autre chose
l'argent de la drogue c'est ça et
sincèrement j'ai homme d'affair j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent je été très
impressionné par l'argent que ça c'est
c'est vraiment c'est des sommes
incroyable
hallucinant c'est juste hallucinant je
vous raconter une anecdote je je veux
pas qu'on puisse le repérer mais je suis
avec un un un détenu et il me dit tu
sais Pierro on a un problème
actuellement ah bon ah ouais c'est le
cach c'est le cash ah bon tu as un
problème avec le casache ouais les rats
le
bouffent les rats mangent le cach c'est
énorme non mais arrê c'est énorme ah
c'est incroyable non mais c'est fou ça
voilà on dit voilà voilà donc il y a
énormément énormément de de choses qui
rentrent en prison tout rentre en prison
soit ça rentre par les parloires soit
par les surveillances soit par les
éjections et on je fait j'ai fait un doc
pour Canal et vous verrez que dans ce
doc on voit où on raconte la vraie
prison vraiment la vraie prison puisque
toute façon notre cher garde des saut ne
m'a pas permis de rentrer de rentrer
filmer en prison c'est on voit une
livraison de drogue par drone ah oui ou
oui mais ça c'est ils ont commencé à
mettre des filets sur les cours
effectivement ils ont anticipé ça parce
que ça existe pas encore aujourd'hui
c'està-dire que les prisons ne sont pas
adapté à la délinquence et ils
envisagent de mettre des filets sur des
filets ça va rentrer quand même pas
Pascal il y a une chose sur laquelle
vous ne pouvez pas lutter ou et je vais
vous expliquer laquelle corruption on a
22h sur 24 pour penser à comment on va
oui donc vous êtes plus fort en fait
c'est ça ce que vous dites mais ils sont
100 fois plus fort vous savez on a une
petite boîte pour le téléphone on a une
toute petite boîte pour téléphone
j'étais avec un gars là pareil 19 ans
responsable de la sécurité et tout ça
bien il était là parce que avec des
copains à cœur il avait essayé de
pirater des comptes Amazon un deal et
puis quand il les a piraté il en est
rentré vous savez des cartes cadeaux je
crois d'Amazon et il en est rentré 20
millions [__] ils l'ont arrêté justuse
àant la petite boîte comme ça j'étais là
je lui dit tu sais moi j'ai un problème
j'ai le câble est pas assez long je je
vois pas bien il me dit et il me dit je
lui dit mais la petite boîte tu l'as
regardé piierre j'ai internet ça m'a mis
30 minutes non ah ouais fort non mais
fort très fort d'ailleurs il est sorti
il a été embauché par une boîte de
sécurité fort bah bah c'est fou bah
c'est incroyable il y a beaucoup de
violence en prison tu nous en as un
petit peu parlé tout à l'heure mais il y
a beaucoup de violence en prison tu nous
en as un petit peu parlé c'est énorme
moi j'ai un jour ils sont battu j'ai cru
que le gars était mort ah ouais ouais
quoi les surveillant rentre pas en cours
de promenade he deux détenus oui de
déten pendant la promenade ouais ouais
mais vous savez on av avait on allait on
avait le droit d'aller le cub4 au
gymnase une fois par semaine le vendredi
matin et donc il y avait match de
foot c'était il y avait pas une fois où
il y avait pas deux gars qui qui se
pétaai le genou enfin voilà c'est une
violence mais c'est vous avez pas idée
de la violence mais mais tout est
violent l'environnement est violent
pourquoi les surveillants ne signalent
pas ces violences par peur ils ont pas
beaucoup de choix parce que ils vont
signaler à qui Cyril d'accord donc ils
vont signaler à qui à leur hiérarchie
ouais à la hiérarchie une fois ils vont
ils vont mettre un criri à un détenu une
autre fois à un autre détenu puis la
hiérarchie va dire dites donc c'est quoi
un SRI vous hein c'est quoi un SRI ah
pardon un compterendu d'incident
excuse-moient un compendu excusez-moi un
comprerendu un compte-rendu d'incident
et donc la hiérarchie la fameuse
hiérarchie va va lui dire vous mettez
beaucoup de CR quand même hein qu'est-ce
qui se passe vous êtes sûr que c'est pas
vous ouais ah ouais ah
par faut parler d' l'éducation il a un
moment c'est un peu comme dans
l'éducation en fait he exactement c'est
exactement ça c c'est exactement ça
c'est exactement ça c'estàdire les
surveillants sont lâchés au milieu la
hiérarchie est en costume on les voit
jamais et ils veulent surtout surtout
pas de problème pour pas avoir un un blâ
ou quelque chose sur Oui mais mais mais
tout à l'heure vous avez dit que vous
aviez cru qu'un un des détenus était
mort après une bagarre s'il y avait eu
un mort là le surveillant mine de rien
c'est c'est compliqué pour lui derrière
aussi de le promenade ouis et alors et
donc il est pas responsable ça peut
c'est c'est en C de promenade ouais pas
responsable c'est pas il est pas
responsable personne n'est responsable
de rien en prison c'est fou il y a des
des bisutages par exemple est-ce que le
bisutage c'est une pratique qui est
courante pour tous les nouveaux arrivés
comment comment ça se passe vous avez vu
non il y a il y a comment dire quand on
alors là c'est spécifique au qub4 he
quand on arrive il y en a un c'était moi
parce que j'étais le plus vieux qui va
qui va vous accueillir entre guets met
dans la cour de promenade qui est voilà
se présente et je lui disais à ce
momentlà deux phrases un je ne veux pas
savoir pourquoi tu es là h de je ce qui
se passe en prison est en prison quand
je sors n'essaie pas de me contacter je
ne veux pas ils le savent tous je dis je
ne veux pas donc moi c'est terminé mais
quand on tu es ici on va essayer de
s'occuper de toi et donc là on lui
demande de quoi il a de quoi il a besoin
et on essaie de l'intégrer le plus
possible dans le groupe la solidarité
détenue est très forte ah ouais ouais
ouais très forte c'est très forte il y a
il y a il y a destenus qui ont des
relations sexuelles en prison alors il y
a une chose qui
m'a sidéré ouais sidéré je me tourne
vers Hugo oui je sais Hugo c'est que
quand je suis arrivé au par rapport à la
première fois à 25 ans pour ça c'est
très intéressant de voir cette cette
analyse entre 25 ans d'cart quand je
suis arrivé
au dans le médical dans les WC du
médical il y a du gel et des
préservatifs c'est pour ça vous vous
inressez à moi oui d'accord tu es
homosexuel tu tu ou oui bien sûr ou oui
ok oui donc voilà
doncou pas que lui
pasussuseais penser à moi
aussens c'est prison voilà c'est ça
non est-ce qu'il y a des relations non
cons est-ce qu'il y a des viols bien sûr
beaucoup parce que on dit que ça fait
partie des bisut justement non je crois
pas à ça non ce qu'il a ce qu'il y a
c'est que quand on est faible en prison
on est faible donc le plus faible en
prison ben voilà il se fait prendre
j'espère que je t'ai pas blessé parce
que je voudrais pas'inquiétez pas c'est
il y a pas pire donc il y a beaucoup de
détenus qui ont des relations mais il y
a des relations amoureuses ou pas parce
que c'est ça qu'on veut savoir aussi
est-ce que c'est que des des relations
consenties est-ce que c'est est-ce qu'il
y a des histoires d'amour ouis c'est ça
qui est ouou bien sûr comme dans la vie
prison c'est pas comme dans la vie tu
marches pas main dans la main avec ce il
sont pas mais non mais non mais c'est
pas ça qu'on veut dire homopob quand
même en prison il y a quand même une
homophobieente m'a beaucoup surpris
d'ailleurs ah ouais vraiment ah bon ah
ouais ouais ça me semble assez évident
non pourquoi pourquoi parce que c'est
c'est un endroit où tous les hommes sont
mélangés il y a une sorte de masculinité
aussi un peu toxique le stéréotype peut
faire du prisonnier c'est quand même pas
c'est quand même pas le le le pro LGBT
hein il y a quand même je pense que
c'est quand même une réalité où en
prison il y a quand même ou mais
pourquoi ça m'a surpris h parce que je
je pense c'est un milieu dans lequel on
est tous très tolérant envers ce que
nous avons fait hein donc
c'est ça pour ça que c'est surprenant
que je trouve que c'est surprenant parce
que normalement il y a une très grande
tolérance entre les détenus puisque
regarde c'est ce que disait pierre à
chaque fois qu'il y a un mec arrive on
lui dit on veut pas savoir pourquoi tu
es là mais on va t'aider donc c'est vra
qu' dans la
tolérance c'est vrai que c'est un j'ai
été très surpris ça également je pense
par
exemple queil y aurait énormément de
choses à faire pour les femmes la façon
dans laquelle j'entendais parler des
femmes wou c'est dire c'est voilà enfin
bon
c'est franchement je pense je pense que
euh il y aurait vraiment un vrai travail
de fond à faire sur on peut on peut
exercer sa religion en prison ou pas
pardon on peut exercer sa religion en
prison oui moi je suis d'origine je suis
catholique de base et puis j'ai quitté
et comme là-dessus je suis comme
beaucoup de détenus je suis revenu à
Dieu en prison d'accord de quelle
manière en fait comment ça s'est passé
tu pierre j'ai quelqu'un qui m'a écrit
de façon très très régulière
et et puis il y a un moment euh il faut
bien confier sa vie à quelqu'un enfin
voilà c'est un cheminement très
personnel je suis encore très pêcheur
hein donc je veux pas voilà je suis très
très pêcheur mais euh
euh en tout cas c'est quelque chose qui
m'apporte beaucoup et qui
m'aide beaucoup y compris dans ce combat
là vous savez je je le dis je le dis
c'est pas évident hein de raconter tout
ça j'ai 68 ans je peux plier et
puis c'est très bien de le dire pierre
est-ce que est-ce que il y a il y a
beaucoup de gens qui pratiquent leur
religion préson
pr donc c'est essentiel vraiment ou
c'est essentiel la religion est
essentiel ce qui m'est arrivé à arrive à
d'autres avec d'autres religions mais ce
qui m'est arrivé à moi arrive à d'autres
maintenant l'important c'est de savoir
qui va vous initier vous guider et pour
quelle raison c'est ça qui est
important pour toi vousas dit tout à
l'heure qu' énormément de récidives en
prison tu penses que c'est on peut on
peut pas lutter contre ça B si si si non
non je pense que le seul combat perdu
est celui qu'on ne livre pas donc euh
non non absolument pas je pense qu'il
faut vraiment changer le le système
carcéral français je pense d'ailleurs
que le président euh
euh est prêt à le faire mais je crois
que malheureusement euh dans notre dans
notre pays le pouvoir des politiques est
très très limité surtout quand ils
veulent pas l'exercer tu peux nous
rappeler combien de temps tu as passé en
prison en tout 602 jours la première
fois 2 ans la 2ème 2 ans tu comp t t les
jours où un moment tu étais tu tu est-ce
qu'il a un moment tu t'es senti bien en
prison ou jamais pardon est-ce qu'il y a
un moment tu t'es senti bien jamais non
mais c'est important parce que jamais
non tous les jours c'est pas possible
impossible
non tous les jours était un cauchemar
pour toi ou est-ce qu'il y avait est-ce
qu'il y avait des jours qui étaient
meilleurs que d'autres ouais un jour
heureux est-ce que tu te rappelles d'un
jour heureux en
prison quand j'ai appris que mes filles
étaient championnes de France de
d'équitation ouais tu m'avais écrit
d'ailleurs ouais c'est vraiou ouais
c'est vrai mon P et c'est mais sinon il
y a le oui parce que je trouve que
c'était très fort elles avaient leur
père en prison elles le subissaient
parce que porte elles ont voulu garder
le même nom et elles auraient pu prendre
le nom de leur grand-père hein qui est
plus prestigieux et elles ont voulu
garder le même nom elles sont j'étais en
prison elles sont fait leur concours
elles venaient me voir hein tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps je
leur ai imposé ça alors que c'est pas un
secret de dire qu'elles sont pas issues
de ce de de cette ambiance là elles ont
été extraordinaires avec les familles
des détenus elles ont je vous racontais
tout à l'heure un jour il y a une ell me
raconter qu'il y avait une dame assez
volumineuse qui ne passait pas devant le
portique et ell lui ont dit ben c'est
votre soutien gorge et elles ont tendu
un boubou pour qu'elle puisse pour que
la dame puisse changer et T tous les
gens toutes les familles ont tourné le
regard et je suis très fier d'elle de
s'être adepté dans tout ça du soutien
qu'elles m'ont apporté et puis du
magnifique titre qu'elles ont eu elles
viennent encore de placer six chevaux
parmi les les SEP premiers donc je suis
très fier de ça on les embrasse fort
pierre boton ex détenu auteur du livre
qb4 je voudrais dire euh ce livre il est
important parce que Pierre boton quand
il a fait ce livre aussi pour que les
conditions carcérales s'améliorent pour
que la société s'améliore c'est vraiment
ce qu'il faut retenir de ce livre et
qu'il y a beaucoup de choses qui partent
de de de de la prison et que voilà ce
qu'on vit parfois dans la société et
qu'on vit tous les jours ça part parfois
des prisons et que c'est c'est pour
éviter aux gens de récidivé ou de d'être
encore plus gangriné en prison il faut
améliorer les les les conditions de de
détention merci Pierre et ton livre
c'est incroyable tu B4 merci tu reviens
nous voir quand tu veux merci à tous
tout de suite le sent de la Vig C
merci